So a couple of weeks ago, the COD team were discussing rotations and I volunteered to
kind of remove myself from the COD team and I gave my reasons why and those reasons they resonated
with the rest of my teammates and they basically said well I think you should tell the company that
so that's what I'm here to do I'm here to talk about myself a bit but in order to understand
these reasons sorry a bit emotional you have to understand a bit about my history
so I was a normal kid and well I thought I was normal that's actually a bit of a statement I
thought I was normal so when I was six years old I basically wrote my first computer program
on a zx spectrum when I was 10 I wrote my first cheat engine so I could um have the video games I was
playing and in sixth form there was a year-long project that we had to do that got externally
marked and I wrote a video game it was very similar to like quote quake or doom that you guys know today
it was very similar written in the same league it's our own graphics engine it had to get externally
marked and the marker sent it back said they don't understand that they can't read it and it was
impossible for any child to have written this so I got zero percent for it I mean obviously the teachers
got me my marks back I still thought I was normal um at the time so then I went to university
I got 100 for every single one of my computer courses in all four years at university
um in essence I could have literally written the exams and not gone to university and probably passed
and because I thought I already knew everything the lecturers the lecturers for computers would
actually come in to me and ask me for help with their computer programs they need help for
and I still thought I was normal at this stage you know because I was nothing special this is just who I was
and then I started working so work for me was very easy obviously I got into computers it makes sense um
I had to go like out of my way to make work challenging and interesting wherever I went
I worked at many companies and I had this like routine where um I go to a company I do like two years of work for
them and then they'd run out of work or interesting work for me to do and it became like really boring
and not challenging at all and then I'd move on and I had the same fear when I came to portsmoke
although you can speak to my colleagues in the pro team I literally raised with it to like you know
we got the small application you know burps with pro it's like I'm going to be done with it in two years
um that didn't happen so during so this was 20 years of my career I spent working doing this
during this 20 years there was a bit of pressure and stress because I had to know like all the answers
weirdly enough and most of these companies I worked for there are a lot of startups and if I failed or if
I didn't know the answer basically the company would go under so there was a little bit of stress and
pressure that I felt and it was during this time these working years this 20 years of my life before I
came here that I knew I was different right I knew I was not normal I was good
and to be honest I was better than good I was the best um
and I have to I have to really get this point across because what I'm about to say now
is less about me and probably more about you guys and so I really want to get those points across
the world I fundamentally knew my strengths and weaknesses to the T I knew what I was good at
I knew what was bad at and I didn't need to work on any of them I don't need to work on my strengths
or my weaknesses because I was just so much better than everyone else right my strengths were so good
and so much better than anyone's and the people in my team are smiling because they know this is true
I've thought this right my strengths are so good my weaknesses didn't matter at all right they were
pointless right also during this time because I was so good and so far better than anyone I actually
like no one to learn from right it was tough at that way and to put for those of you don't understand
the people in the world and to try like to just get this across I came up with this analogy I was like David Beckham
and my teammates were toddlers
and my opposition was toddlers okay so I hope you understand this word here right
and I'm not because that's I fundamentally believe that to my core and then I joined port swagger
and for the first time in my life in 20 years I'd found my people
so just let that sink in guys I'd finally found like my people um it was like I'd been walking in the desert
alone and then I found civilization which is basically you guys um a lot of people here suffer from
imposter syndrome I know that because I've spoken a lot of you I had reverse imposter syndrome because
because I was so comfortable here I was surrounded by you know Messi and and Ronaldo now when I was
beckon and the pressure went away as well because all these other companies I knew if I didn't know the
answer basically that was the end but over here I could fail and I knew someone else would know it
was awesome I felt so good and for the first time since I was basically six years old
I could actually learn from people it was awesome
but of course thanks to uh my previous speech you know what happens when you join a group where the
strengths are as strong as yours your weaknesses start to shine they stick out like a sore thumb
and I've never worked on my weaknesses because I don't need to and I started getting constructive feedback
right and because of who I was and I hope you understand that I struggled with this feedback right
it just didn't make sense but thanks to Raji and I created a lot of this to her but she probably had
support around her like a culture team and stuff who gave her the tools to work with someone like me
he was like basically probably a complete asshole um I was able to process this feedback I didn't say I
took it all on board but at least I was able to process it with her help so even with this feedback
I didn't change or I didn't think I changed because even then I still had this incredible sense of self
I knew what I liked I knew what I didn't like I knew what I wanted to be I knew what I didn't want to be
an incredible sense of self so I processed the feedback and took it on board and the thing is over four years
I grew as a person without actually knowing it it's hard to explain and people have told me
like the shore you know six months ago very different to the shore of four years ago but that was not
because I was trying that just happened because I think of the people around me it's just you know like
a rising tide rises all boats so everyone around me being good kind of raised me so
then cod happened and this is a big moment for me um I don't actually know what happened in cod I'm
still processing it it's quite so much changed you know as everyone knows between november and february
there was a massive upshot so I don't actually know what happened but in cod there wasn't much programming
not much computers there was a little bit but it was like completely outside of my content zone
right there were problems that couldn't be solved I was doing things that are outside of my skill set
we also failed a lot which I'm not used to um another thing that happened in cod was
there was company-wide interaction so when I was in the pro team I was sort of isolated in the pro team
um but over here I've actually got to like meet and interact with all of you
from through various means I heard your struggles your pains your ideas your solutions
and I was blown away
in 20 years no one impressed me but you guys did
I was amazed by the people and the school year I have and something clicked but it wasn't like an
epiphany it was over this entire um course of my time on cod right and I wanted to raise my game now
because I met all of you and I actually saw the excellence around me it's like I actually want to get
better and actively work on it which is very different to what was happening before where
Raji was making me better without me even knowing and so I actively engaged in my growth
I started asking for help and there was tons of it
I got a development coach he's really pushing me
and to and I started working on my portrait and to show you the quick turnaround of this
the portrait came out in November last year and I remember looking at it at the time and I'd already
been here a long time looking at the portrait and saying this is not for me I don't need this
I was wrong I actually started working looking at the portrait working on it and it's like it was
amazing tool
I volunteered to leave um cod and I can literally say it's the best four months of my working career
and I would I would love to stay in cod forever because it's so good I mean what what might change
but what I learned while in that car team is I really want port so I get to succeed because of you guys
I'm not doing it I'm not doing it I'm not doing it I'm not doing it I'm not doing it I'm not doing it
I'm not doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it I'm doing it
so these are my tweets that I learned so this is the summary of everything going on
if you work at Portswiga you're good that's just a simple fact straight from my mouth doesn't matter what anyone else is telling you I'm telling you that
if you think you can't improve you're wrong
there's a lot of support learning here
let's just ask anyone you can walk up to a random person and ask for help and it's it's amazing what
you're learning and many people fear change but if you want to be amazing you should embrace it
before I end
I just want to specifically thank people out there
and I don't think anyone's done this before but I want to thank those people that gave me constructive feedback
you know who you are there are quite a few of you quite a few
but it was thanks to you guys that I'm actually here today I'm actually super happy
do you have any questions